Ever since the start of periodic videos,
I wanted the Kips operators that sits on the windows,
still in my office to be used for video.
This is it right here. Now that's been cleaned up. It was covered in dust.
It was actually a Kips operators. K I P P a apostrophe S.
Now Kips operators is a piece of operators that was very
important in past times, but now it's never used.
A chap called Kip, actually invented this back in the 18 hundreds.
And it was used for generating gases,
carbon dioxide, hydrogen sulfide, and hydrogen.
And sometimes I believe sulfur dioxide.
Because then they didn't have handy things like gas cylinders that got delivered
by, um, companies. So they had to generate the gas as they needed it.
In this machine, in the middle globe,
you put a solid material in this case, calcium carbonate,
which will react with an acid to give carbon dioxide.
And at the bottom, we're going to fill this with dilute acid. In this case,
we're going to use hydrochloric acid, two moles per decimeter,
cubed concentration. So in order to get this into the bottom,
without it touching the middle part, we actually fill it from the top bulb.
And if I just take it out,
you can see that the glass tapers and actually take
out all the way. And actually, if I turn it,
you can see it's got a hole at the bottom.
And that enables us to bypass the middle bowl
and allow the asset to get all the way to the bottom. So we've stopped it.
In the top.
You pour in hydrochloric acid and the acid goes down the tube
into the bottom and then comes upwards and reacts with the calcium
carbonate to make carbon dioxide.
So at the moment, there's not quite enough acid.
So I'm going to close that valve, get a little bit more acid in that.
[Inaudible].
Okay.
I'll open the valve just to get the liquid
into contact with the chips. Like so close the valve again,
we've got enough acid. It's come into contact with the chips,
calcium carbonate dust. That's what you're seeing leaching into the HCL,
but that's fine because all that's going to do is generate our product,
which should be the water, the calcium chloride and the CO2 gas.
If you have the outlet, tap closed, the carbon dioxide,
which is a gas is generated, but it can't escape. So as it's made,
the pressure goes up and up and up as it goes up,
it pushes the liquid down the acid down, back down where it came from,
where it came from. So it goes down and some of it goes up to the tube,
to the belt in the top. When it goes down, of course,
it's no longer in contact with the solid. So the reaction stops.
If you didn't have this liquid going down,
then the pressure would just build up and up and up.
And you have an explosion.
Neil.
As a rather nice little demonstration based on the same reaction,
which shows what happens. If you'd let the pressure build up,
it's a little plastic bag that contains calcium carbonate and
acid. And when you break the seal and mix the acid in the carbonate,
the plastic bag expands and suddenly goes off with an enormous
bag.
With capes.
This doesn't happen because the pressure pushes the
acid away and the reaction stops. So it's a beautifully controlled reaction.
You can see the, the, the model, which was,
which was submerged just now they're being exposed.
When you open the tap, the pressure goes down,
the acid comes up and generates more gas.
So you keep on getting gas until the acid runs
out. Or the solid is all digital.
[Inaudible].
Let's see if we've made some CO2 open the tap and watch what happens.
We've now put the pipette so that it's submerged.
The tip of it is submerged inside that solution. Now that is copper sulfate.
So if we put the CO2 in, assuming it is CO2 that we're making,
then that will bubble through and we should get a precipitate about typing the
tap now. So you can see there's the hole there. As soon as I twist it,
that hole will allow, um, the gas to pass through.
So now we've got this keeps operators working.
It's important to show you that we're really making come dioxide.
So you need the good test.
And I wanted to have a test which also looked colorful.
So you'd have a nice video that would give you pleasure.
So I suggested to Sam, a series of transition metals, souls,
which should give precipitates really nice colored combinates
CO2. Plus a transition metal gives an insoluble carbonate. We've got.
Other metals, salt solutions, try the copper sulfate.
If it would have gone by now, if it was due to go,
I don't know why it's not working. This is science and action for you.
So we're going to take it out.
What's put it in the ledge Knight tree.
So Simon Neil made that the solutions
and they didn't work. What went wrong.
I sat there watching the guests was bubbling through and nothing changed. Well,
either I got the chemistry wrong or they made the solutions wrong.
I think it's just doing this because.
It hates me, I guess, probably I got the chemistry wrong. So in the end,
because they have good chemical knowledge themselves,
they went for the classic test for carbon dioxide,
which is line water line water is the solution of calcium
hydroxide, which reacts with CO2 to make calcium carbonate.
In fact, the solid that they started with.
There you go straight away. You can see it. That's brilliant.
It's definitely CRJ. Fantastic.
Of course, because they thought of the right thing to do. It worked perfectly.